hello freak bitches it is what it was
just like any other problem that people
go back to I mean at some point it's
it's up to you to release yourself from
that obligation to get upset or feel bad
about something that didn't go right in
the past you know and that's a huge
point because people define themselves
by the past instead of thinking about
who they are now and set up they still
look back at a mistake they made and
don't just get past that mistake
grow and learn but dwell on it think it
defines them it's the worst thing I met
some guys in band uses singers I've only
met him twice two different times years
later both times he started tell me
about this story about what happened to
him when he was in this anything in this
poor guy has gone on all these years and
he's still focused on the worst
situation that he ever had to live
through yeah and he's so attached to it
well some guys get one breakup and
they're done some guys one breakup in
their 20s will tank them for a decade
I've met guys like that that yeah you
know it came out here with Sally and you
know she fucking fell in love with her
trainer and dude Sally still move on
what is that an fucking years ago
oh oh you know changed my life bro but
Tiger toy are you so disappointed I
can't trust women anymore
uh-oh you stupid fuck you know what if
he got mugged by one person he'd
untrusting people every exactly I'm yeah
one person was a murderer let's not
trust anybody yeah yeah you know I heard
about Ted Bundy I'm not trusting people
anymore okay great I'm not sleeping
tonight we yeah I mean there's
definitely pitfalls in life you're gonna
run into him
we all are no you can learn and grow if
you survive you pick yourself up you
dust the dust off and then you start
going and I don't let this stuff don't
let it beat you down it's also directly
proportionate to the amount of hardships
that people face in life their ability
to face hardships you know and there's a
lot of folks that live life on a cushy
cloud of marshmallows and bullshit and
then one day something goes wrong and I
mean that's why spoiled kids are so sad
like a spoiled young boy is one of the
saddest things ever a young boy that
becomes a man and can't take care of
himself
and his dad has to keep on rescuing him
his dad has to keep on bailing them out
of situations and giving them
I've met guys like that and that is a
crippling affliction when they don't
have the character themselves to be able
to get by in life they constantly need
someone to help them and bail them out
even as a grown man I've met guys in
their 40s that still need help from
their parents I'm like what the fuck man
you're never going to get it right
because somewhere along the line they
didn't face enough of the adversity to
realize that there's sometimes you just
got to get up and get shit done there's
sometimes we have to fucking pull
yourself up and you have to push forward
even if you want to stay in bed and if
you don't do that you just keep calling
on your daddy and your daddy keeps
rescuing you
you never develop those tools you never
develop that ability to recognize what
you're doing wrong with your life
because you're you're soft you got a
cushiony you got a safety net a safety
net for your safety net I have this
friend and she has this uh this friend
that she's been friends with for decades
and his poor fuck his family super super
super wealthy like unbelievable wealthy
billions of dollars and he had that not
only did he had he had a trust fund and
a backup trust fund so he blew through
the trust fund and then he blew through
the backup trust fund real estate
investments and just disastrous business
ventures no character no discipline no
ability to stick it out but incredible
amount of resources he had millions and
millions of dollars just pissed it all
away didn't understand it completely
depressed and one day said to her he
said you know cuz she has children as
well and she has sons he said to where
he goes whatever you do do not give your
kids money don't give them a fucking
penny goes especially your boys don't
give them a penny that ruined me don't
give money wow it's deep shit to be a
man like in your late 40s looking back
at your life this disaster wreckage that
you put forth with the millions you've
blown now he has like a retail job
his parents fucking abandon them I mean
you look at that and you go whoa this is
this is wild shit man
the guy's just still struggling from the
way he was developed from the the tools
that were instilled in him at a
childhood and in you know in adolescence
and having that safety net just provided
him with a way to stay in bed kept him
weak never developed character now or
have an opportunity every time things go
wrong every time things feel terrible
you have an opportunity to learn from
whatever makes you feel terrible and
never allow it to happen again
exactly yeah thank you that push forward
don't don't do it again yeah you know
learn from your mistakes we all make
them
that's where meditation comes in
recognizing that and solidifying it in
your head and I believe meditation the
tank which is more magnified form of
meditation I think it's more intense and
I think that you can you could really
get something out of that if with those
sort of ideas in your mind about
constant consistent improvement and it's
only the only thing that you'll allow
from yourself is to maintain a certain
standard then consistently try to
improve and do that do that and you'll
be a happier person
that's an amazing concept there to
become a part of to where you're
involved in Europe the construction of
your own character yes through your own
efforts and your own evaluation and then
to to make the right steps and make the
right decisions that you become even
stronger as you go